[Music]
when welcome to our live show the Monday
evening blitz shoulders oh just look at
start early this video why is that I
hope everything is good and you see it
hear me alright let's get some blitz
games in I got the sound on right yes
okay so five-minute game requested and
um yeah what I guess is all now so maybe
it may be written began one of those
match up then hmm that would really have
such a great doesn't really look all
that great here my picture
I wonder but even worse not really great
a bit strange anyway I got a game
requested I hope you guys had a good
good week and yeah I don't challenge
anybody somebody says challenge or the
gas I don't think he doesn't even play
regular blood see only place the pool
like I do so um yeah looking forward to
getting game in the pre toilet we've got
one bottle our chests 32 that's a new
opponent what is barrage has good to do
so I'm going to go with the classical
reply and he plays the bishops game so
yeah and we transpose into the carrion
while the mysterious openings really I
don't ever understand the different move
orders and turtles
yeah like the I always play the same
moves but sometimes I feel like I don't
understand why I do them in there in
this particular order or different order
or whatever this c4 f5 complete rubbish
yeah of course
why should they be that's a bit of a
weird question 94 mm okay maybe here
near it's a little bit uncomfortable
yeah 95 at Bishop e7 was not a 27 wasn't
a very a very good decision problem this
is a bit uncommon but I didn't you
really feel I have something else there
were multiple threats this looks a bit
strange really castling long yeah I
wondered Queen e6 there's actually just
a caption just happened so I have to go
back what resources do I recommend for
playing Knight f3 d5 g3 and I don't
think there is something great to be
honest I think I think that actually I
am yeah I should probably do something
about it
write something publish something about
it Knight f3 g3 I think it's something
that would interest many people
and there's nothing really good release
so queen a4 so I'm ready to play Knight
d4 him you know I would like to go d5
get some counter flavor at the end there
is d4 so this is not really all that
nice I think I have to I have to
centralized number one no interesting
but here we can maybe get something to
deform 95 and so yeah he wants to play
before I completely understand
I have 94 though yeah maybe I should do
this immediately
[Music]
I think this way it's less likely for
IKEA queenside attack to work
then across the night now 95 I can go
seasick see you there's nothing wrong
with that and Knight f5 I mean ok I
covered d4 and then he has to go to e3
and so on so that takes quite a long
while I could try h5 this to h5 that's
interesting
threatening h4 and then g6 which traps
the night I doesn't react to it and all
I even have d5 in this position I don't
know if that helps but that's
interesting Bishop is 7 an interesting
question about the semi Slav with Bishop
g5 on move 5 why Bishop d7 is not played
more it's not particularly great I'm
actually gaining yeah Bishop e7 is not
particularly great because you get into
good Queens gambit declines I playing
quick Queen c2 a loop d1 yeah I've
gotten some counter play here and he has
to be really really circumspect here
and what what Jacob saw it is suggesting
is really not good a 45 93 d6 d4 f5
doesn't work it just doesn't work and
okay
yeah 95 is one way to do it here or
check and check him that's maybe even
better check not sure yeah I'm in here
95 a media click also comes a to
consideration
check this is simple and pretty good as
well so long right is 594 I have f5 and
they also have 94 here oh I didn't think
about that
I haven't f5 escutcheon control for me
no black it's not ok what you're
suggesting without contrast is just a
good Queen's Gambit yeah f5 this is 9 e4
e5 Knight f3 d6 d4 f5 what's credos
regional idea but it just not really
doesn't work yeah here after Knight f5 I
play Knight to f3 and I think I'm
winning
okay so just g51 you can do many things
96 is also just good yeah just set that
wins material it's probably the easiest
thing and okay so I can take it this is
also pretty good take it stronger 92 I
have Queenie to check check
quite resigned yeah I was surprising
that a somehow got a good game there I
don't know what happened really
somehow the age porn push God system to
be dangerous okay Gordon game we tired
and I've got shade I think this is a
grandmaster right yeah
when master shade and we can test this
immediate level yep here why doesn't
have have anything better than thank you
for here brilliant yeah this is a funny
looking line
the idea is Quincy one and then Bishop
h6 or Quincy one easy form this is not
not too bad now Bishop h6 it can take so
I go see form interesting okay but
that's not so bad I think of course
black is okay I'm not arguing about that
you might might come to d5 the Bishop
III is probably not that great yeah I
think values rights is the land that you
give that you think that you give us
actually I think good for black if you
feel that silly for for black I think
you're wrong the whole white line is
actually not good I think it's hard to
give the whole whole line now here it's
a line of the ecig will be six defense
the English defense
as it is often called em the black queen
doesn't have squares maybe not a big
problem that's still going to try to
erase it
yeah you say you lose against I
understand I think you said you lost
with white if you lose with white that's
normal because it's not good for what
but but black I mean okay it is really
it is very very sharp so okay so he's
going to try Bishop h3 which is not a
big issue
okay let's decentralize maybe Bishop f5
and doesn't do it
I just coordinated a little bit better I
mean black is quite active but I still
think I should be very ok I have to
avoid before I think after that Bishop
g4 is an extremely annoying pin so that
I cannot allow it's difficult however to
come to do something active I would
really like to get rid of his pieces
there they are pretty annoying h5 and H
3 this Knight to f4 would be good too ok
so it tries to somehow get rid of my
one night add to the cafe there some
some some discussion in the chat about a
particular line which I could give some
input to but it's hard to actually keep
you informed about it okay I try to
bring the night over to force my idea
and also how does it cover B seven would
be eight Bishop f4 might be on what what
about Bishop f4 I don't understand it
says something I overlooked yeah but I
take it right I cannot take it I can
take it like this okay yeah well I
thought I just go back one maybe uh no
yeah I think I'll just go back
so let's see yeah I mean I was wondering
if I can take and play em and play Queen
to f5 here maybe night if two or some
rubbish is working
I could work okay what okay let's go is
sixth I'll just open this up so if I
take now the Queen takes and now like
Queen to g6 isn't that annoying here for
him look f8 no and I don't know it looks
good for me right or did I not see
anything here
of course I mean if he distracts my
nighttime checkmated but I currently
just threatened 96 winning and how does
he play so 96 but maybe I have something
better
96 is not threatening watches the thing
now that's or tickets why not
or now I know it no one I'd move huh oh
I should have thought about this a bit
more
what would happen here
yeah this kind of thing kind of warning
yeah that wasn't good and he see still
alive which you should not be check us
this whole rubbish setup okay probably
not good
[Music]
try to play books e7 double on the
seventh it's difficult to prevent ya
like this but should really do all that
much look at seven I actually did not
look at this all that much which I
should have done check such a more catch
him [ __ ] I am spoiling this tool and
winning position check check check check
[Music]
check check check
white for fates on time then I was silly
I should have just won this game map
anyway it was a good fight I mean is
obviously quite high rated so but I
shouldn't lose I'd really okay okay I
already get a new game requesting
[Music]
what I guess is still on and he is not
playing at the moment so there is a bit
of a Leawood started nope playing doodle
it ok d for whom let's play one bank oh
and we for okay I go for the clothesline
which is not what what the beep
I cannot not take it I mean that's not
possible but what is this stuff okay you
need six might be possible okay so we
five I guess
is pretty Ricky
okay I mean this this doesn't work
anyway but how exactly do we do it I
want to I really I don't want to spend
too much time g6 maybe I don't know
[Music]
oh my god if you play complete maniac
that I'd like this one yeah you always
feel always feel somehow weird
okay so take this and now we should be
seven probably
I had so somewhat unclear him I was a
good move actually maybe
jae-won there I should have thought
about Gucci one goddamnit
then now we get to 95 and then things
don't things are not clear I am I'm a
[ __ ] should never be in this position
after White's crazy game I mean look at
this mu played 9 pawn moves in a row
unbelievable
yeah now some some some stuff might work
here I don't know why that works however
[Music]
check what a maniac I didn't get
anything I don't know anything
help you know it probably takes two
minutes to let the clock run down that
would be a perfect mo what the heck
now you let the clock run down typical
yeah okay while we wait here
I can welcome everybody again in the
chat we have tons of regulars in there
I'm really happy that you're all around
I feel a little bit like yeah I don't
know what is that what's the English
word for that that in German we have
yeah the word thumb to share the kind of
place where you do every week same time
same place and you kind of meet for
drinks and on well well the drinks I
don't know I only have water but yeah
I'm taking these these points just have
to wait a little bit
hmm somebody in chat mentioned be 496 d
4f v while that shouldn't work i mean ii
496 93 f5 is the colorado gambit and
this isn't I mean it doesn't really
really work but it is not as rubbish and
it looks I think I saw on pretty decent
players struggle against this the
Colorado the weather in Germany is
actually I don't know I mean how it is
same in other areas but here it's really
ok we are in the low to mid 20 Celsius
degrees really really ok yeah 20 seconds
still on you might make a move at like 2
seconds hoping that I'm away as well but
I'm not
can make some kind of primo why tell me
what a long time in coming challenge
No so more Childers and next one I'm
going to get trying to get a new five
minute pool opponent doesn't really yeah
what I guess is on the whole time but I
don't get him
yeah please if you've got a question go
ahead in the chat why don't people in
Germany embrace air conditioning hmm
yeah I mean it it depends I think you
might have you have probably new
buildings that are built in a way that
are yeah from - from they are built so
efficiently that they shouldn't get that
hot in the summer so you don't even need
air conditioning I think this pretty
much applies to to new buildings but the
place I met is almost 50 years old and
they did not have air conditioning back
then the summers weren't that hot and we
are actually waiting the whole time for
game that's weird and you can up or get
started but you can of course think of
getting it later
like now I can I'm actually thinking
about it for next summer getting air
conditioning because I'm simply dying in
my office sometimes it's so hot so what
are you doing here and D 5 a 6 play
wants to be clever yeah
90 45 actually does lose a piece now
still too good I think I'm winning a
piece now yep I win a piece she still
has a pretty big Center so it's still a
bit of work to convert yeah I think if I
go for some air conditioning it pretends
to be something reasonably serious like
something built in into the wall or
something okay and now I get the default
square which I'm quite happy about
oh he's blundering the house that's good
black resigned bit of a strange game
there okay but if they give me the
points yeah gimme gimme yeah a real AC
system that's probably what I have to do
but it's something that I probably will
go for next year I mean it doesn't
really yeah for for this year doesn't
really do much I'm here for like six
roughly six weeks and then in my my
summer holiday and when I return I think
the Sun has probably already gone okay
takes a while to get new opponents a bit
strange and what I guess is locked out
what a shame
game started oh that the the the madman
again what is he doing now just letting
the clock run down oh my god yeah and I
see has no way to stop this game this is
really a crap app actually if they don't
move in the first minute they should be
for faded and and gone wow this is crap
thank you
draw effect not going to resign here
I cannot abort the game
I can only resign it will have an atom's
two points he will not let this run down
nor for five minutes
yeah I'm going to Slovenia again yep
for three weeks roughly looking forward
to that no Al Bundy where's the question
I didn't get the question ah why don't
use Blitzen no I don't use blitz and I
switch to switch to - - awhile back like
an oak 10 years ago maybe longer and I
don't intend to switch I'm happy with
the software I think it's a bit more
comfortable than Blitzen but it's it's a
matter of taste people of course still
use Blitzen but I don't
yeah I'm sorry I'm not going to give up
points maybe at some point the software
will be changed but you used to have
those people yeah I will play I will
play in a tournament in early September
in in the very young short five round
event this is what I have on the cards
will be roughly into month and I'm also
looking to play and in October but
there's nothing then nothing definite
yet end of October something but we have
to figure out which it went yeah I'm
sorry about that but not much that I can
do you cannot abort it can try it again
but no aunty also doesn't make it wrong
no I cannot avoid it
and I cannot blacklist ignore on eyes
you see in the pool I cannot do that
either
and I play tournament in autumn book
Bavaria which is near on path off near
pass all
you have just one minute to go maybe you
will make a move on when he is on 50
seconds or something this can actually
be somewhat tricky I have had this the
same situation also the other way around
50 seconds to go
yeah the thing is this is really the
cool thing there brought requests
I cannot withdraw so we can still aboard
it now or with one second yeah I cannot
abort the abort you know I don't think I
can actually let me check
nope I cannot cancel it so he can still
avoid it now place four heads on time no
he did oh my god okay a new game that
guy again I don't know it doesn't happen
I have gained a couple of points already
session which is not bad but it doesn't
make for good TV
yeah it's hard if you have people who
abuse the system it's difficult I do it
doesn't happen all that often right it I
have a new request out and there are
actually quite a number of people on but
so again get started
aha dr. mabuse's okay so what is the
doctor playing in the Sicilian I'm kind
of curious g6 okay
yep now we go for the society even Queen
takes even cream cakes is interesting
now with this inserted or maybe actually
maybe actually this Oh
so what about can i play let's play
against f7 here come you cannot
challenge me yeah it is it is it is we
playing in the pool so I wonder here 95
immediately putting some pressure there
it's kind of funny when I think this
isn't all so easy should like to play
if six dachshund or no night age six
interesting so clean b3 no can also just
do this ask him about this night it's a
very strange very strange position tough
to evaluate it looks pretty weird I mean
if he cancelled short how is he ever
going to use this night on the other
hand me canceling long is also not that
easy
so yeah 95 I don't know Knight to e5 oh
okay yeah I get the point you probably
wants to play f6 but that looks
absolutely weird so let's put it back
okay so we cancelled short just develop
here maybe be five huh
maybe d5 yes such a fool
a stupid that was stupid allowing the
five some such wrong now now blacks
position makes sense before that it was
just not good at all
really not good at all
[Music]
pawn takes pawn takes meaning now not
what I wanted around it
no no Markos what you suggest is decent
but I did not want that I wanted
something a little bit more forceful but
that is a decent more
check
check parents already weird check time
morning
now this avoids the drawer it's probably
complete nonsense I didn't want to draw
it is got in five now now we have to
check immediately
something a group the aid is probably
good chick coming yeah that's probably
rubbish which I hadn't made to make a
move check check
yeah I did not really want it this kind
of thing but check I don't know am I
lost
check check check
I guess not check which is kind of funny
check check
black for fits on time um yeah that
wasn't very very clear
I guess Wow okay
I was probably mine is a million but
okay let's a regression game I cannot
bend someone I can check absolutely not
okay so I got a new leak went out and
what they actually I scored well yeah
the session I win all games right no I
lost against shade but it was a good
session yeah it was a really smooth game
you can say that
yeah um who else is on I got the request
out and pretty good rating game really
no there are a couple of cool guys on
but they they mostly play bullet I think
the way I see it
Larry Christian was on his own or Larry
Christensen I'm not sure how I should
pronounce that to be honest and but I
think his teachings gained laying a
started F do model who the heck is F
tomorrow and yeah
Banco style people don't want any fun
okay
what the beep probably don't have to
take but at least this is not just some
boring London system Christian zone yeah
million Christensen I'm terrible at that
Bishop to b4 would be cute to get
dissing but he will probably prevented
you
yeah so we got some kind of exchange
sloth out of it is 95 mo let's do it
just being a past here the thing is the
black queen doesn't have that many
squares and the white queen the black
queen the White Queen doesn't have that
many squares if this is one of the
squares if I don't Knight to b3 now if I
go if five in this position for c8
where's the white queen going or is that
point X rook c8 Queen D form doesn't
quite work night b3 instead working this
Bishop c7
I'm spending too much time okay I'm
trying this if it doesn't work then so
be it
pawn cakes I think if he takes with the
piece I have night be three books e8 or
just looks the aid immediately winning
stuff pawn takes only move then Knight
b3m attacking the rook and threaten Luke
c8 trapping the Queen very weird
maybe maybe it takes with the porn and
the sacrifices very weird 94 maybe takes
93 94 we should be 5 as an idea
94 maybe there okay that's funky
wow-wow-wow one one will appear will
appear
okay check so he's giving me a look
probably tough to rescue the might right
so my king position is not good but I'm
will look up at the moment a full look
maybe just develop stuff this this 95 is
dangerous from the more dangerous than
95 it's very straight it's it's tricky
it's still a pretty tricky position
check yeah
I cannot have two one
well I mean I can go to g8 maybe that is
safe
okay so d5 is hanging oopsie - probably
not I should probably keep this cover
this somewhere Queen b3 is rubbish f3
coming I don't know how to play yeah I
could have gone to e6 Sam and maybe that
was stronger not just for fun I mean it
might it maybe was stronger because it
keeps the ropes connected I can go with
here though if you want to do me
something funny and this is actually and
this is actually maybe reasonable not
just rubbish or play it for fun it could
be a good option time morning
24 Maivia
keeping everything on the board
threatening whoopsy one check check
check
ah there's a check on you aid actually I
didn't see that coming
ah shoot I crap he's winning this
rubbish I don't believe it now can black
resigned okay
poor yeah I mean okay I mean this was
certainly completely winning who black
but it was tricky very tricky maybe King
to you six I mean here white is just an
exchange down there's really no doubt
check maybe King e6 I don't know and
okay one more game
one more game we had to sweat this this
weird waiting stuff with with this guy
let's see if I can get one more game
game started I Westphalia and play
playing quite frequently so 9b d7 so
let's see what we get
so let's see f5 is now g5 and I can do a
couple of things so this is one of them
that's reasonable
maybe I can play for h4 h5 and it can be
interesting let's see if I get this in
okay so I would like to play g4 it would
be nice to be able to play but not
really to do
Knight h2 is got f5 it's not that great
mainly this for now putting some
pressure there
f-five does not work now night at 7:00 I
can actually go G for all night H to
earlier that was f5 but now this is my
idea
preparing g4 and f5 doesn't work so I
might get in G form
so if it provides us but how tortoise
fighter Sidra Wow what
really
what what to weird stuff okay but I
don't have to take immediately you can
also do this
I'm not sure that I want to take the
exchange I think I just go here
[Music]
yeah I think what he did wasn't totally
unreasonable I mean in a know if he
plays normally he's just acutely busted
and this at least looks somewhat strange
somewhat strange is wrong way to put it
yeah let's say Messi and I did not think
about the check unfortunately I
completely forgot about this bloody
check
and was very unnecessary
maybe just no look h6 threatens queen g3
pretty pretty badly what what I don't
understand anything
so I don't know I don't I don't get it
check
and I can also check here right check
he's got this check here but it is just
a check one time morning check I think
this should trade queen song check here
what is he doing
King yuan I don't see it black resigns
nothing okay okay it was a very strange
thing to happen I have no idea Oh some
of those rules okay I hope you you
enjoyed the show there were some some
strange things going on but I've gained
a couple of points I'm happy about it
yeah thank you all for watching I'll be
back next Monday with the regular time
regular place I hope you are all joined
got a couple of yeah regulars today hope
you all be there next week as well
thanks for watching guys bye bye
you